Clinical trials are studies by
scientists that test new ways to prevent,
detect, diagnose, or treat disease.
Scientists ask volunteers to help
test new medicines or ways of
doing things during these trials.
Some of the things that
clinical trials test include:
New devices, such as blood glucose testers for
people with diabetes, pacemakers, or implants.
New drugs, such as painkillers,
medicines that lower your blood pressure,
or treatments for cancer.
New vaccines,
new ways to do surgery or other procedures,
such as a new kind of knee replacement,
or surgery to repair the heart
after someone has a heart attack and
new routines to improve a person’s health,
such as changes to diet and exercise
Clinical trials have helped us learn
how to live longer with illnesses
like cancer, high blood pressure, or
diabetes. Clinical trials have also
helped us use vaccines to eliminate some
diseases like polio in the United States.
Each clinical trial has a research plan that
explains in detail how the study will be run.
This plan includes information about who
the scientist will ask to participate.
Sometimes scientists are looking for people who
have a specific disease to participate in the
clinical trial. Sometimes scientists need healthy
people to participate in the clinical trial.
The purpose of a clinical trial
is to determine if the treatment,
prevention, or behavior changes that are
being studied are safe and effective.
Clinical trials are reviewed, approved,
and monitored by a group of people
not involved in the study. This group makes
sure that the study is being conducted in an
ethical manner and that the rights and
welfare of the participants are being
protected. These groups are called
Institutional Review Boards or IRBs.
In the United States, a clinical trial
must have an IRB if it is studying a drug,
biological product, or medical device
that the U.S. Food and Drug Administration
(FDA) regulates, or if the clinical trial is
funded or conducted by the federal government.